the reverse bucket list is something I
do oh boy to ever do it and it took me
too long to figure this one out
when I was
50. I'm 59 years old when I was 50 I
found my bucket list from when I was 40.
you know I was a classic thing and my
birthday I would make a list of my
desires and my ambitions and I would
kind of imagine myself visualize myself
consuming or experiencing these things
and it would fire me up and make me well
kind of feel like a loser quite frankly
because it was it was it was lowering my
sense of satisfaction I subsequently
found out and I looked at that list for
when I was 40. and I checked everything
off that list and I was less happy oh no
at 50 than I was a 40. I'm a social
scientist so I thought to myself
obviously I'm doing something wrong what
am I doing wrong
and basically this is the problem this
is a neurophysiological problem and a
psychological problem all rolled into
one handy package
I was making the mistake of thinking
that my satisfaction would come by
having more
and the truth of the matter is that
lasting in stable satisfaction which
doesn't wear off in like a minute
comes when you understand that your
satisfaction is your halves divided by
your wants halves divided by ones that's
the model so you know it's like I'll
slow down because I know people watching
it like let me write that down halves
divided by ones you can increase your
satisfaction temporarily and
inefficiently by having more
permanently and securely by wanting less
I thought to myself
so what does that mean and the answer to
that what does that mean is I need a
reverse bucket list not that I'm not
going to get nice things in my life but
like I'm going to be consciously
detached from them by going through the
exercise of writing them down and
Crossing them out
so on my birthday now my 59th birthday a
couple of months ago I wrote down all my
ridiculous Ambitions and desires of
money or whatever power ambition
admiration all these things that I want
from other people that we all want
because we're human and mother nature
wires us to to accumulate the rewards
that'll help us survive and pass on our
genes I get it I know how evolutionary
psychology works
and I know that these things are going
to occur to me as natural goals but I do
not want to be owned by them I want to
manage them I don't want them to be like
phantasms in my limbic system managing
me I want to move the experience of
these Ambitions to my prefrontal cortex
which is my executive manager the bumper
of tissue right behind the my forehead
and the way that you do that is by
looking at each one of these Ambitions
and saying maybe I get it and maybe I
don't
but I'm going to cross it out as an
attachment and I'm telling you Tim I'm
free
and so you found that to work it works
it works it works it does not because
you don't care about it but because
you're not attached to it in the same
way you've made the decision to have it
not be a a rootless desire a ghost in
your head you've made it into something
that you will consciously manage by
literally experiencing that ambition in
a different part of your brain